je pense que nous sommes de très
nombreux touristes qui font du tourisme
parfois en masse parfois en se
concentrant mais ce n'est pas je pense
qu'ils caractérisent
l'expression n'est pas bonne le tourisme
de masse al'inverse ceux qui veulent
s'en détacher sans distinguer dans tous
les sens du terme emploie volontiers le
terme d'éco tourisme
ce qui donne bonne conscience parce que
c'est censé respecter davantage les
milieux d'accueil les populations
d'accueil et surtout une façon de se
mettre à part me semble-t-il est de
conserver une certaine façon si son
compte asseoir
dès lors qu'on dispose des moyens
notamment financiers et culturels de le
faire donc je crois qu'on est souvent
sur un faux débat à ce sujet et partager
c'est l'avis de saskia sur le fait qu'il
ne faut pas d'emploi attendent à travers
le terme de tourisme de masse mais
plutôt veiller à ce que par des
politiques adéquates et cela se fait
déjà dans beaucoup de pays qui soit
d'ailleurs porter ces pays par les
politiques de gros sous de daurade
prenez le cas des seychelles qui est un
pays qui a été aspirée par dix ans les
idéologies non pas socialiste mais
communiste pendant longtemps et bien les
seychelles ont une politique qui est
résolument une politique sélective basé
sur l'argent et ne reçoivent qu'un
nombre contingenté de visiteurs dans des
conditions de qualité voire de luxe qui
sont tout à fait remarquables
donc ce sont des choix qui sont tout à
fait connu qui s'appuie sur des méthodes
des techniques de gestion des flux très
en amont parfois à l'arrivée rarement
sur le terrain beaucoup et notamment et
c'est ce à quoi je pense en france on va
payer de plus en plus aussi payer une
meilleure répartition dans l'espace
meilleure répartition dans le temps de
ces flux tout en veillant à la qualité
et à la minimisation des effets négatifs
que ces flux peuvent avoir donc c'est
une question de nombre c'est vrai mais
pas nécessairement de masse
à
[Musique]